Oh all right we're here in fire
California and I'm the new mayor I work
all the time I'm a little bit tense
whenever I take time off what's some
advice that you have for me the advice
is just to put your hands in the staff
you know be ready at 5:00 dude I'm ready
not so much I'm we're going to find out
what I do for fun are you ready to
unhook your bra not wearing a bra
we're about five minutes into the trip
and you're working I'm Jane well I am
currently in a car on my way to a
utopian city that's been founded by
David Hasselhoff gonna have to take his
final him
[Music]
great give me the mayor yeah what's it
like I've been bringing more
responsibility to this than they gave me
what are the top five things to do here
at phoner to ensure that you have the
funnest time possible the best things
you can do your underarms eggs a spa spa
is awesome number two is a food the food
is great it's good casino food there's
nature trails all over the place the
pool it's got the lazy river which is
about 90 degrees it's got eight jacuzzis
well they have a micro brewery and you
got sweets like the hoff sweets with all
my stuff from puff lands well we say
this on The Skeptical is having fun you
want to get away from their lives get
out of your world let it go forget it
don't have a good time sure you guys
he is like America's cool uncle after
speaking to him I'm a little more
excited about this place well we've got
his list of suggestions so what should
we do the nature trail first and just go
through I'm done let's do it
there's nature trails all over the court
I won't rest so the boy relaxes oh he's
having fun having fun David ancient
abacus it's wrong Andrew the red ants
are getting my shoes I think we should
get out of here
get out of your world let it go
SR 76 beer works is a first-of-its-kind
brewery in Southern California fully
owned by the Rincon tribe with sanyo
Indians we're making beer David and
really smells like bread yeah
this possible
oh yeah so when I grew up as a kid there
was a Wonder Bread factory down the
street Farah and this reminds me of that
it smells like the outside of a subway
in heaven hey shall we to the ha
there's nothing like an afternoon here I
feel like you've gotten brighter
[Music]
what are you doing
I feel responded that Andrew gets a
facial today the spa spa is awesome
hey J put the phone down we voted you're
getting a facial today although I'm a
little nervous I've never had a facial
before exactly what happens they just
touch your face don't feel I'm feeling
like I'm having fun how's the massage I
wanna marry him I'm about to 2-bit our
pool is that lazy which is
Pam commits the water to is nice but
it's pretty great
my drinks at the bar
[Music]
I do feel like I'm missing out
[Music]
we're gonna lose enemies where's your
phone
charging
[Music]
we definitely have a fun attention none
that I can show you he's like point
oysters good casino food
[Music]
Oh dignity when this landed in our faces
I was already scared I'm so is there
such a thing as too much fun for you
[Music]
you haven't picked up your phone all
night realizes I'm watching your every
move very present
I just really liked having fun with my
friends you know that when I bust out
the lacto Bionic acid pad it has been a
fun day
[Music]
back to reality it's good to remember
that fun is healthy wait you said fun is
healthy
[Music]